i wanna uh i wanna ask you we we talked
about 2022 what about 2024 you think
trump is gonna run do you think desantis
is gonna run so
today i believe that donald trump is
running for president
i have talked to him a few times he has
not tipped his hand but everything that
he says and how he says it what he cares
about like he's in
could it change absolutely
but i do think if trump runs no one of
significant runs against him there is
it's just i mean and if they want to
they can but he will crush them if you
look at the system iowa new hampshire
nevada south carolina by the time they
get to super tuesday it'll be over um
but if he doesn't run
i keep hearing people say he should play
like this elder state that's not trump
he doesn't he's not the elder statesman
that's not the role he wants to play he
wants to be in charge and get things
done or not in and i think he's going to
do it he needs to be the guy who grabs
the other person's microphone and goes
excuse me excuse me no listen as opposed
to the
waiting to be respected right that's
what people like about he's not and so
there's not i don't see a role where he
says hey let me be the behind the scenes
guy that's not who trump is yeah what
about desantis i think if trump doesn't
run there's no question in my mind
desantis is the immediate front-runner
he's sort of the next version of trump
he's he's younger i think he's better
with the media he's better with the
media i think he's handled a lot of
culture cultural issues very very well
uh what to see is policy positions i
think you know one of the things that
really sold me on just being like i'm
gonna vote for trump school choice was
big i really am a big fan of that um
ending the war in afghanistan was big of
course we might have kind of ruined all
that
but i would i would honestly
just right now based off a very
preliminary view i'd prefer desantis
over trump i didn't vote for trump in
2016. i'm not a fan of of the of the
character you know i understand why
people are
but i will say i suppose if it is trump
i'd probably vote for him again well
look i mean here's the reality i mean
just from a political sense if he runs
he's the nominee yeah i mean it's just
maybe i think desantis is going to give
him a fair running because first of all
but i don't think a descent just runs
against him number one number two again
if you look at the early states and
again part of this comes down to how the
game is played in terms of how do you
accumulate the 1500 plus delegates
needed to be the nominee and right now
the system and the grassroots and
everything favors trump so if he runs he
is the nominee i agree and if he doesn't
run i think desantis is the presumed
front-runner there's some others things
happen barack obama you know wasn't i
mean he was a state senator four years
out trump was still on tv i mean like
there's enough the time that somebody
can emerge but i would say
looking at the field today desantis is
the presumed frontrunner if trump
doesn't run who would you prefer
probably trump i'd imagine i i think
look from a selfish standpoint um trump
but i i don't i actually like desantis i
like how he's governed i like how he
pushes back of the media i like how he
look one of the things that i thought
was so great is during covid when he was
getting all the flack at the beginning
for how he's handling it he stuck to his
guns he said this is the right thing to
do and he didn't bow to public pressure
and polls and i i like that i'm so tired
of watching someone pick their finger in
the air and say hey what's the right
decision i think desantis has core
values
that i may not agree with every time but
i know he actually believes him and he
means it and he'll fight for him what if
it's trump desantis well
i can't imagine a scenario where
desantis agrees to be the vp yeah yeah
he's not distracted to be president
right and he also two guys that are
chief executives like that don't i mean
you don't want to play second fiddle
trump is always going to be the alpha
dog and so he needs somebody
who plays that role well and after and
2028 you know desantis sure well could
come in we'll see i mean that's the end
of it but again if you think about it
every time that you try to game the
system politically speaking
and say okay well in five years i'll be
there it doesn't work i mean you either
run when you think you should run and
you don't but uh i just don't see a way
that you could overcome trump's
political advantages in this in the
system people are saying ron paul 2024
in the comment section and a lot of
people are saying brandon 2024 i think
brandon would be a good running mate yes
trump brandon trump brandon but it's
like literally not a person it's just
the sentiment people are voting for
mm-hmm i agree with that i don't know
just find that alone i'll vote for it if
people know the meme
uh well if you don't i think most of the
people who listen to this do get oh
definitely but i got a shirt
yeah i i do get a kick out of the fact i
mean that goes back to the point that
we're talking about the media i always
think it's funny when you show you
expose the stuff
the idea that that reporter stood there
and i mean like i was just like it
didn't rhyme it's not like biden rhymes
with brandon i mean like how do you
how do you come up with that but it just
shows you
how complicit these guys are that no
matter what they said they were just
like well they can they're
congratulating you brandon when i went
on your show it was actually really
funny because when you played the clip
you hear
beep joe biden beep joe so it's like the
bleeps right and then i was just funny
trying to hear it and you guys are
bleeping it and it was so obvious that
the bleeps are every like second and
this lady's like let's go brandon
it's great it's great i mean again that
goes back to my it's it's it's it's
raining outside and yet
you're being told it's sunny it's like
how do you possibly get let's go brandon
out of f joe biden i mean i i'm sorry i
don't know if there's some kind of latin
etymology etymology you go back in time
you're like well if you decline the verb
do you have
that's the flag you need luke let's go
brandon i already ordered one it's on
its way and i already had a t-shirt and
it's the best seller on the store right
now really yeah let's go brandon shirt
uh but ours is a little bit more
explicit because it says let's go
brandon in big words but it has uh the
alternate definition it has the
alternate definition as it's uh
shade yeah as a shadow so uh
i will say you know as a segue off of
this the two things that are fascinating
in politics to me right now just in
terms of someone who's been studying
this for a long time or one when you
look at these trump rallies you got a
guy who's not running for office on like
saturday nights jam packing the alabama
one 35 40 000 people i don't know what
the attendance was in in iowa
and or georgia but tens of thousands of
people who are spending their saturday
night going out and seeing a guy that's
not running for office that's number one
on the exact opposite i'm watching these
football games rallies et cetera where
people are yelling
f joe biden yeah i mean i've never seen
either reaction in po in in modern
history where you've got a group of
people going out to support a
non-candidate in this case trump because
they believe in him and the movement and
and people at like
public events yelling this political
thing political things you know in a
huge stadium and it's not like you know
how sometimes you can hear a faint chant
i mean this is something that's like
overtaking the entire loving football
stage i got this image on instagram
uh i tagged it let's go brandon
and the reason i did is because we all
know what it means we went i went to a
restaurant this past weekend and there
were two signs in the window the first
says dear valued customer due to covet
19 our food suppliers have sharply
increased the price of our food
regrettably we are forced to raise our
prices for the first time in seven years
thank you for your patience and
understanding as we face these difficult
times and the sign next to it says now
hiring huh the funny thing is they put
coveted 19 in red letters on their sign
and i'm like it should read thanks to
joe biden right and both signs should
say thanks to joe biden these are his
policies where in his presidency it is
buddha judge it is his appointees this
is one of the reasons let's go let's go
brandon is at public sporting events
i put let's go brandon on this i put it
on twitter i got over a thousand
retweets people understand the problems
yes maybe not everybody but enough
people are seeing this and they're
recognizing so i think let's go brandon
is the perfect phrase for these times
because it allows you to convey an idea
wrapped in you know kind of a little a
little a little nice friendly package
yeah and it's clean yeah yes
it's a very dirty phrase let's go
brandon it's like a real it's like a
real life meme uh but but everyone knows
exactly what you're saying and you know
what i called back for though by the way
i don't know if i should feel bad but
it's like people who are named karen you
know
and i'm like you wake up one day and
you're like how did i become a bad
person and now you're like this there's
a bunch of dudes named brandon that are
walking around like hey life is good
yeah let's go brandon now sean i i
really i'm dying to ask you a question i
hope that's okay well thanks for coming
by tonight
catch you later now now as you know
press secretaries kind of sell stuff
yeah what was something that the
administration came to you with trying
to sell that you were like oh my god no
is there anything that was like oh crap
do i have to do this
i know there's there's some people
handbags that ivanka knocked yeah yeah
i know there's some people talking about
these handbags to one of your answers
there are some people talking about
inauguration there's some people talking
about the syria strike um about those
comments that you made before well i
mean there were things that we sold i
remember early on um like the travel the
the travel ban i think we we
how we sold that was
horrible i mean in terms of like we
didn't have our act together we didn't
have the full list of countries and the
method so there were things that we
tried to sell that frankly i just don't
think we did well because we were new
and we didn't have all of the our ducks
lined up in a row um
but there wasn't anything that was like
oh my god i can't do this it was more
like if we're going to do it
we've got to have everything lined up
ready to go and and that happened more
often than not i think one of the things
that i was proud to have started and
then i left is that after we kind of
blew health care we i said okay we're
we're now i mean i remember one day
walking into the roosevelt room tom
price secretary of health and human
services at the time i looked at him and
said okay where are the where are the
groups on us like you know they're
getting ready to do all this repeal
obamacare and he's like which groups i'm
like i don't know the ama the doctors
he's like yeah no no one's with us and i
was like okay this is a problem so when
we knew that tax reform is coming up
next in the queue i literally was like
we're having a meeting every day we're
sitting down we're lining up our top
folks and uh and we're gonna you know do
this right yeah but you know out of the
gate look he was it was it was exciting
and different new but you know we
definitely made a fair share because i
could imagine it's definitely not an
easy job and for me personally i'd be
like okay i got to sell this um and and
it'll be interesting you know to to
understand the kind of psychology of
what happens behind the scenes because i
feel personally i'd be like oh man i
don't want to sell this everybody you
should well first of all this goes back
to what we said a moment ago tim was
bringing some i mean you're a
spokesperson so i mean no one's sitting
there saying hey before you go out do
you agree with this it's this is your
job you know it's your rep your analogy
about being a sales rep it's you don't i
mean maybe there's some products that
you don't want to necessarily that's
what i'm kind of asking for that's not i
mean i've had to say things over the
course of all the people that i've
represented they don't necessarily agree
with but that's you either quit at some
point or you suck here's here's one of
the things i was bringing up earlier
i'll mention this passively one of the
famous instances that you were
criticized criticized for was trump's
inauguration i've heard that the the
claims
largest audience ever you can sit here
and say oh yeah there are definitely
things i didn't agree with and try and
give at least a more honest view of what
the job was like and then the media is
going to run sean spicer admits to being
a liar right they'll
they'll never go after sackey that way
no and the fact of the matter is look
i've said this from the beginning it was
a three-day weekend
uh we wake up after the president takes
this historic
uh
you know uh good gets inaugurated this
historic comeback campaign and wins and
we wake up and this is what they're
talking about and so we're trying to
cobble together
basically a case that says this is
stupid who cares you know we how many
like think about what we're doing right
now live streaming a show with tens of
thousands of people right that didn't
exist when obama was president so i was
like okay we've got people that were
live streaming things on twitter and
people that were and so that's the
context they want to include right so my
point was how do i basically make the
cases this is a silly argument and a lot
of people did they were excited about
president trump i know from my own
family that there were security issues
getting to the to the mall because of
increased uh issues and routes and all
this stuff so i'm trying to make the
case and everyone's like nope nope nope
nope nope but this is this is a very
important thing people need to
understand in in any election
dc overwhelmingly democrat yeah democrat
wins 90 people walk out their front door
and they're standing there correct rural
areas vote for our president they're not
flying two thousand miles to make it to
dc some did
when it comes to voting for instance you
know and i'll say this passively i don't
derail the conversation but with like
mail-in voting why is it so powerful for
democrats because they have one
apartment complex with a thousand voters
in it they can knock on all those doors
in a day a conservative has to go to
rural areas and drive miles between
houses in some instances but also i mean
yeah or they go to a union hall where
everybody's there they fill it out right
now
that doesn't have i mean it's just not
the same and it's it's so so when i when
i saw this i remember seeing the story
and i didn't care about you know why i'm
like oh did he mean live streaming or
something i'm not going to get into an
argument about a spokesperson's
upselling the president even if it
wasn't the case yeah well and anything
with seki i i don't know make sure this
is clear because now i'm going to know
the left is being like who's just
showing no i said the same thing of seki
i don't blame seki for not getting asked
by journalists but but i will just say
this just to be clear i don't think we i
think we could have done a better job
and and just so everyone understands the
president i get back from the briefing
room the phone ranks the white house
operators like the president's on the
phone and he said some things that
cannot be
and repeated thought okay hey you want
me to go out and
explain to people that this is
ridiculous
that's not what he wanted he was pissed
that's what i wanted that's what i was
really interested in and i do have to
admit the way that they treated you and
the way that they're treating saki night
and day total difference and it's just
it's just absolutely crazy to see uh you
know how the questions they ask you and
the questions they ask her it's it's
crazy one of my favorite memes is stop
making me defend trump there's this
comedian who did a video where he's like
in the workplace and there's two guys
saying something ridiculous about trump
and he hears it and he goes guys that
that's not true trump didn't do that and
they go
what are you far right he's like no no i
just they said something that wasn't
and so he's like every time he defends
trump like why are you defending trump
and he's like because you're wrong so
there's a cheryl atkinson came on my
show i don't know six months ago or
something she mentioned this this book
that had come out there's a professor at
the university of houston he's a
journalism professor and he makes clear
first thing he says in the book is i
voted for and supported bernie sanders
so by no means do i support donald trump
in any way but he goes through every
single one
of the media narratives that trump is
accused of you know this um good people
on both sides this that what i mean all
those things that trump has supposedly
said that whatever and he says here's
exactly the transcript of what he says
here's the context in which he said it
so you know there's and and hear all the
and it's like this guy literally breaks
down
every one of these things
and makes it clear i don't like him but
it's what you're saying to him where
they're like he's like i just want to be
clear what the truth is about what he
did say
not what cnn's headline was
right and and it's just amazing i didn't
realize some of this stuff there are
things that trump said that i just
assumed okay i assume that he didn't
really mean that or whatever but then
you go back and you read it and you go
he actually didn't say what the what the
cnn's and the washington post of the
world very fine people hoax right it's
it's it's amazing how you can have him
say they should be condemned totally
completely omitted from from the right
any other transcript right right but i
loved the fact of actually stopping and
saying like and and you know not to make
it personal but there were so many of
these things that happened to me
there's one that that became really
famous was like spicer hides in the
bushes there's no bushes to hide in
i mean like i don't mean to be a jar and
so i'm arguing with the washington post
editor the day after that story comes
out right and he goes okay all right
we're going to say that you were near
bushes
and i'm like i have a picture this is on
everything that happened was on camera
so i i finished a tv hit and i walked
over to where the media was there's a
row of hedges that you have to walk by
like
it's i mean like there's no you know
what like and and so the washington post
is like all right we'll change it to
your near bushes
what does that have to do with anything
except for an attempt to try to
undermine and demean the president it's
the game they play i once had a story
written about me that was actually meant
to be favorable
and i get a call from a fact checker i
was the new yorker that did this and it
was this crazy story about me and my
buddy hackers and journalism and so so
the fact checker goes so it it says here
in the story that you live in a closet
and i said uh i no i don't live in a
closet you're denying it but no no no no
no hold on
it's like a closet right and i was like
no it's a full bedroom with a window
yeah but like but like you have to go
through someone's apartment like
someone's room to get into it and i said
have you ever lived in new york new york
has something called railroad apartments
have you ever seen those where you have
a living room bedroom bedroom bedroom
they're connected because of the way the
buildings were built and i said this one
isn't technically a railroad when you
walk in the living room there is a room
but there's another room attached to it
separate you goes right right like a
closet
and i went right like a closet and then
they wrote tim poole sleeps in a closet
so annoying but that's it's again how do
we want it they have to they pick a
narrative
my my friend uh made uh spaghetti with
white sauce took like alfredo and olive
oil with rosemary and garlic and whipped
it up and the journalist is like so
you're eating sauceless spaghetti
noodles and he goes
well i made a white sauce i'm italian
and they're like
like not marinara like not like a red
sauce and he's like
yeah but i made like an
alfredo like a white sauce and like yeah
you know what i mean but like not not
tomato sauce and he goes
right no sauce would you just give up at
that point because you know they're
going to justify right
right right right it's like
but
and then they ended up writing this
ridiculous story about us but the funny
thing is a guy from gq saw it believed
it and was like i want to do a feature
profile on this and then showed up and
was like none of it was true huh i'm
like yes here's my bedroom with my
window in my bed
it's amazing though but once they write
one thing like that then it justifies
every other reporter from using that as
a fact as if it's gospel right because
well it was written once before
therefore it must be
and that's the problem and and you know
i mentioned this before but there are
literally two chapters in the book that
go through the media and how complicit
they are and what they do to cover up
for this because it's not always what
they write it's what they don't write
man
journalists
at least in in this beautiful idealized
world where the fierce
independent folks challenging the
establishment holding the the powerful
to account
when in reality they're literally just
working for those people to sell
products by the way i'm watching the
comments and one of the guys says fact
checkers and i'm like you want to talk
about like if you go to school and
you're in high school and you literally
have no skills the guidance counselor at
one point comes up to you and says like
have you thought about becoming a
fact-checker like i think that's what
happens because these folks literally i
i
when i left the white house i had all
these anecdotes and at one point mike
pence
uh had given the speech about how many
people were out of work and let's just
say hypothetically the number's like a
thousand people were out of work and the
washington post gave it four pinocchios
because it didn't lack the elect the
context that well a thousand people were
out of work the population had grown
therefore and i'm like
no no all he said was this is how many
people are out of work but they deemed
it 100 false because it lacked the
context and i'm like that's
that's not how people talk
they they uh
that's that's how the game is played my
favorite is when bernie sanders and
trump both gave the exact same stat
something about inner city kids not
having jobs and politifact said bernie
was mostly true and trump was mostly
false because what do either of those
statements mean
mostly true mostly false
the point was the exact same trump said
you know 51 are out of work but bernie
said the same thing they said trump was
lying bernie wasn't well again you've
got to that's how it works thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you